californians are one step closer to
seeing their governor
removed from office as the petition
recall gavin newsom
is at 1.9 million signatures a little
more than that
two weeks before the deadline our next
guest is a restaurant
and distillery owner in the state says
the recall movement became his business
after lockdowns threatened his
livelihood cal wise spirits company
owner and distiller aaron berg joins
us now aaron thanks so much for being
with us this is a big milestone 1.9
means they're probably going to hit the
threshold
are you hopeful you'll get there and
that gavin newsom will be recalled
i feel incredibly hopeful to to see
those numbers i mean i
i have signatures sitting in my business
right now that have been collected yet i
assume a lot of other businesses have
signatures too i i think we'll surpass
two million no problem
when customers walk in and you you you
give them an option to sign the petition
i mean how
what's the percentage rate when they say
yo yeah i'll sign that
yeah i mean at this point most people
who come in have already signed it but
uh almost everyone who hasn't already
signed it does
uh because it's very easy for them to
connect the docs and realize hey i just
tried to come into my favorite
my favorite bar to taste some delicious
spirits or
have a meal i can't do that right now
and there's one man who's in the way
of me being able to do that in a
responsible way and it's very
easy for them to make the conclusion of
i have to sign this petition to
let that happen again sure now but aaron
i believe gavin newsom's opened
california up a little bit right you've
now been open
for a couple three days am i right and
are you
are you gonna pull take back your recall
and say thank you for your crumbs
mr governor uh no not at this point
uh we were just able to open up three
days ago indoors we're one of the few
counties in the state that can
and even then we're only at 25 capacity
um
and i'm not holding my breath because
we've been here before i i i
kind of last count but i think we're at
about seven times that i've had to to
open and close my business in the past
year so
i i i'm kind of happy but i'm not i
haven't
i haven't let a sigh relief come out yet
because it's i just don't know
if it had been up to your local
officials and there hadn't been a
statewide mandate on things would you
have been open
a lot sooner and in different ways
absolutely our local officials have been
awesome they've been trying to reach out
to the state and trying to work with the
state and
let us open because our hospitals have
been uh relatively empty here in san
luis obispo county
um people have been very responsible
here the cova has not been widespread
and they want our businesses to be open
and uh and it's we we've already gotten
in response to silence uh newsom has has
ignored our pleas
and uh he's literally backed a wild
animal into a corner and now we have no
other option but
to lash out in a way that that's
recalling him
he's ignored ignored your pleas but he
cannot ignore this petition
aaron berg good on you for speaking out
for a lot of business owners that have
been squashed by those statewide
mandates we appreciate your time good
luck with the business as well yeah
thanks for having me on